I mean one of these remarkable things
which just happened in the 20th century
is really the growth of the NGOs or the
civil society and you see that
particularly in democratic countries
like an Indian or three million
non-governmental organisation many of
them mom and pop we have 45,000 I'm
totally in Russia itself so while then
throughout Carnegie and Ford Foundation
and so on you know the big guys which it
doesn't bother me very much but their
own indigenous people are very important
like they are in our country to me good
governance is really essential for
prosperity for a sense of belonging to
the community and so on you can't belong
to to a community which led by a corrupt
government for example and so on so I
think for all of that it is very
important that we have the civil society
because it is really even if the
government wants to do good things it
has no way of knowing what the problems
that the ground level are and the NGOs
the civil society provides you with the
eyes and ears of good governance you may
have a you know you can't pull you
you've got to pay a tax if you would but
if you don't know the pollution is
occurring you know the your lawyer
sitting on the books in New Delhi
whether it exists you know the capital
account and it's happening somewhere in
near one of the 50 miles of Bangalore
how are you going to find it out unless
there is a little NGO you know I'm a
democratic system where this is allowed
to function their courts since also so I
think the civil society is so important
and we often make this point in the
relationship
two on the right wing on the you know
right which says don't leave things to
the private sector because they're close
to the ground and they have a profit
motive so they will they really should
be left for do things Bureau class you
know don't ever have that so I'm making
a similar point on the other side of the
left is it work which is to say they
have the altruistic motive to do good
which is the corresponds to the profit
motive in the right-wing argument for
not intervening and they have the
ability to work with local knowledge so
I think the most important thing for us
and is to encourage the civil society
and to support it everywhere but this
doesn't mean that we must have Oxfam I
mean these are gigantic businesses today
you know it's with billions of dollars
being spent I mean Oxfam is a son half
the size of the World Bank believe it or
not and it's just um it they get into
everything and they should just stick to
famines that you know flood relief and
so when they're fantastic but this is a
trouble that I would say I'm against big
size let me put it this way both in NGOs
and you know people getting too big
because leading to monopolistic
practices and so on and I think you know
strengthening media democracy and so
that's the only way to get good
governance and I think we hear this is
where we were to encourage increased
activity by our system and preferably
through into yours themselves and
through because if governments get
involved
problems